une brique de lait avec la photo du
producteur ne sut pas de quoi en faire
un fromage vous allez me dire eh bien si
justement c'est l'idée qu'a eue la
fromagerie delin et c'est l'histoire
qu'on vous raconte tout de suite
monsieur le directeur bonjour alors pour
faire du fromage on sait qu'on a besoin
d'eux lé seul et depuis peu vous en
faites autre chose
et oui tout à fait donc le lait on sait
que sa matière première fois des
fromages
nous on a aussi besoin beaucoup de crème
pour faire un homme fameux brillat
savarin et on a donc du lait demi écrémé
qui restent et aujourd'hui on le met en
briques
alors c'est ici que ça se passe là
qu'est ce que c'est oui tout à fait donc
au coeur du sinn c'est l'écrémeuse c'est
une centrifugeuse qui tourne à 6800 tour
et qui va séparer le lait de la crème
alors 25 mille litres de lait qui vont
partir et qui vont devenir 25 mille
briques
l'idée de cette brique qu'est ce qui l'a
motivé au départ premièrement c'est
l'empreinte régional créé vraiment un
circuit court avec du lait produit dans
notre région est consommée dans notre
région
la deuxième c'est vraiment pour nos
producteurs de lait leur permettent
d'avoir une rémunération responsable à
400 euros du mil quand on sait
qu'aujourd'hui c'était en moyenne
nationale payés entre 300 320 euros du
mil des briques à l'éffigie des
producteurs et du lait dont la crème et
donc à les enrichir les célèbres brillat
savarin de toutes les tailles
il en sort de la fromagerie près de
30000 tous les jours alors vous pensez
bien à kissi
[Musique]